to choose a partner is the most
important job interview we're ever asked
to carry out around half of us get it
very wrong not because we're inept but
because we are wounded we might think
that there would be a minimum of
training and some hazard lights to guide
us but our dedication to public safety
and squarely at the door of our dating
interviews we're supposed to need to be
left strictly alone to follow our
misfiring instincts out of some peculiar
fear of infringing on our liberties we
are abandoned to make our own beautiful
disasters generation after generation
without drawing the slightest benefit
from the sufferings and late life
realizations of others and therefore
with horrifying predictability the most
cautious among us routinely come adrift
without discerning the multiple
cataclysms they are incubating and which
may take a good two decades fully to
come to light
what above all else clouds our judgement
is something we have scarce control over
and a seldom granted the opportunity to
explore in sufficient depth our
childhoods and more particularly our
messed-up childhoods
for the single greatest predictor of
unhappy adult love is in a process that
layers misery upon misery simply and
squarely our miserable time at the hands
of significant others in our early lives
it's expecting too much to think that
one might have been substantially
unloved or troubled as children and then
grow up to make any sort of reasonable
or successful choices in our adult years
the best we can aim for is a live
appreciation that our instincts are
liable to be profoundly unreliable
guides to our future contentment which
might inspire a commitment to getting
someone else
a wise impartial judge to check and help
us with our homework
is some of what happens when our
interviewing capacities have taken a hit
firstly we can't sift what singles out
the emotionally damaged from the more
robustly healthy is not their
involvement with mad candidates these
are everywhere and they're often
irresistible EDA lightful on the outside
it's their propensity for being unable
to spot the problems in due time and
extricate themselves with a requisite
ruthlessness and decisiveness above all
a difficult childhood induct us into
getting interminably stuck secondly we
aren't a friend to ourselves the reason
for the stuckness is hugely poignant
that we don't like ourselves very much
therefore when someone blows hot and
cold lets us down plays games with our
minds makes and then routinely tramples
on promises denies as tenderness and
swears they won't do that nasty thing to
us again and then promptly does our
first second and hundredth impulse is
never simply to up sticks and leave our
tendency is to wonder what we might have
done to provoke the problem whether
there is something that we have
misunderstood and whether we might learn
to be more skillful in not upsetting
them going forward our past gives us a
touching but ultimately disastrous
tendency to think against ourselves and
give an unnatural degree of credit to
the other it might take us a decade to
make a simple realization that someone
else could have reached in an evening
that they're not worth it thirdly we
can't disappoint anyone looking after
ourselves requires a rare skill a
capacity at selective moments to
disappoint another person in the name of
our own protection
to remain sane we may have to say no to
a party decline a friend's suggestion
swerve an invitation and in love upset
someone else substantially even when
they have in many areas being kind to us
to someone who doesn't possess a full
tank of inner love how dare one turned
down the love of another even if it
comes wrapped in tricky or poisonous
elements how given who one is dare one
makes someone else
cry fourthly we hope too much children
who grow up in the company of difficult
adults cannot change or get rid of their
caregivers through a position of
impotence they settle on doing one thing
extremely well hoping against hope that
these adults will magically change and
learn to be kind if they just hold on
long enough and a sufficiently polite
and compliant then maybe the difficult
adult will take mercy and alter their
course these suffering Souls then take
their misguided patients out into their
adult relationships with similarly
negligible results they are barred from
a crucial insight that health at points
involves a lively capacity for giving up
on certain people
fifthly we are overly scared of being
alone our readiness to exit an
unsatisfying relationship is partly a
measure of our confidence that being on
our own will be bearable and open us up
to future more gratifying partners on
both scores an unhappy regard for
oneself will continuously undermine our
reasonable expectations who else would
have us and worse how could it be
pleasant for any decent person to spend
time nurturing someone like us how much
better to watch our best hopes crash
helplessly against the shores of our
current partners obdurate and quietly or
even unconsciously sadistic personality
lastly we find kindness boring a
troubled pass will make us unusually
unforgiving towards genuine kindness
when it comes along nice people feel
instinctively boring unsexy queasiness
inducing an eerie we may be unable quite
to put a finger on what feels wrong with
our very kind dates we may say there was
no chemistry or that our interests don't
align but if we were able better to know
ourselves what we would express would
sound a lot stranger that certain
candidates feel wrong because we know
that they will be unable to inflict upon
us the sort of suffering that we've
grown up to feel is essential to our
sense of feeling loved but they are
wrong
because they threatened to be kind in a
better arrange society there would be
instruction in the art of love
interviews from an early age and a
process of vetting at least as strict as
that applied to learner drivers we would
not be left to crash our lives without
some prior help and counsel for now many
of us should at least be aware of the
extent to which our impulses will be
profoundly misleading when the early
years were filled with suffering we
shouldn't blame ourselves just accept
that we need to learn how to do a very
unfamiliar and for us really rather
extraordinary thing treat ourselves well
if you enjoyed our film you might be
interested in our range of books on
topics such as relationships to explore
click the link on your screen now
you